I had the strangest experience last night. I have these tapes, recorded on my answering machine 10 years ago. Tapes that I had not heard in a decade until last night. And I don't think I can play these tapes for you. I don't think that the people on them would give the permission. On one tape, there's a brief conversation between me and this woman who I lived with for seven years, accidentally recorded by the answering machine just as we were splitting up.
我昨晚经历了最奇怪的事情。我有一些十年前录在答录机里的磁带。直到昨晚，我都有十年没听过这些磁带了。而且我不认为我可以把这些磁带放给你听。我不认为录音里的人会同意。其中一盘磁带里，有我跟我同居了七年的那个女人之间的一段简短对话，是在我们分手时被答录机无意中录下来的。
And on this tape, she's calling me from the street to say that she's going to a movie with a friend. And I tell her I'd like to come along. She's Gotta Have It is the movie that they're seeing. And she indicates no, that I'm not welcome. And then I tell her, "Well, I guess maybe I really do have too much work to do and some laundry that I have to get done." And later in the conversation, she asks if I'm going to be up late, and I say no. And she says, "Well, I thought you said you had all this work to do," like she's catching me in a lie. I mean, she is. She is catching me in a lie. But you know, a lie that I kind of made at her bidding. And then she asked me if I'm absolutely sure that I'm going to get her laundry done that night. And I tell her I'm sure.
在这盘磁带里，她从街上打电话给我，说她要和朋友去看电影。她们要看的是《她一定要有它》(She's Gotta Have It)。她表示不希望我去。然后我对她说：“好吧，我想我确实还有太多工作要做，还有些衣服得洗。”后来在谈话中，她问我是不是要熬夜，我说不。她说：“嗯，我还以为你说你有很多工作要做呢。”听起来她好像在拆穿我的谎言。我的意思是，她确实是在拆穿我。但你知道，那谎言是我应她的要求而编的。然后她问我是不是绝对确定那天晚上会帮她把衣服洗好。我告诉她我确定。
It was hard to listen to. I can hear myself being so scared of her in this tape. And in this same conversation, she talks about this guy who, just a few weeks later, she got involved with, her next serious relationship after me. And I talk about this woman who I was just about to start seeing in this serious way, after her. And that part of the conversation is very awkward, very awkward.
听这些录音很痛苦。我能听到自己在磁带里是多么害怕她。而在同一段对话中，她谈到了那个男的，仅仅几周后，她就和他好上了，那是我之后她的下一段认真关系。我也谈到了那个我刚要开始认真交往的女人。那部分对话非常尴尬，非常尴尬。
And before I heard this tape, I could not have remembered much about that summer, that summer where we were splitting up in 1988 after seven years. But hearing the tape, it all came back. Where we lived, what was in the apartment, what we used to wear, how we talked to each other, and how I felt all the time when we were together, this way that I don't feel anymore. And it messed me up.
在听到这盘磁带之前，关于那个夏天，也就是我们1988年相处七年后分手的那个夏天，我几乎记不清什么了。但听到磁带后，一切都回来了。我们住的地方，公寓里的东西，我们过去常穿的衣服，我们互相交谈的方式，以及我们在一起时我那种始终如一的感受——那是我现在再也没有的感觉。它让我心乱如麻。
And it wasn't like looking at photos. Pictures are posed. Pictures are these tiny little-- they're tiny. You can hold them in your hand. They're 3-by-5. You can crush a picture. This was not posed. And it was not small. And part of that, I think, is just the power of recordings. And part of it was the fact that we were on the phone. There is something about being on the telephone. It's just so intimate. Talking to a person on the phone, you are right there. You are so close. It's like you're whispering in each other's ears.
这不像是看照片。照片是摆拍的。照片很小，非常小。你可以把它们拿在手里。它们只有3乘5英寸大。你可以把照片揉皱。而这些录音不是摆拍的，也不是微不足道的。我认为这部分是因为录音本身的力量。另一部分原因是我们在打电话。打电话这种事很特别，它非常亲密。在电话里和人交谈，你就仿佛身临其境。你们靠得那么近，就像是在彼此耳边低语。
There are these tapes of Lyndon Johnson on the telephone in this audio book called Taking Charge by historian Michael Beschloss. And Beschloss makes the argument that without these recordings of Lyndon Johnson on the telephone, an important part of Johnson would be completely lost to history. These tapes are so raw. We hear him operating on people in this way that is so-- Beschloss makes the argument that it rarely comes through in transcripts of meetings or public events, him just trying to charm people and flatter them and play on their weaknesses and strong-arm them.
在历史学家迈克尔·贝施洛斯(Michael Beschloss)的有声读物《掌权》(Taking Charge)中，有林登·约翰逊(Lyndon Johnson)的电话录音。贝施洛斯指出，如果没有这些林登·约翰逊打电话的录音，约翰逊的一个重要侧面将从历史上完全消失。这些磁带非常真实。我们听到他以这种方式操纵别人——贝施洛斯认为，这种方式很少出现在会议纪要或公开活动中——他只是试图去吸引人们、奉承他们、利用他们的弱点并强迫他们。
And he's more honest on the phone than he was in public. In public, Johnson said that he believed the Warren Commission report. On the telephone, he admitted he didn't believe in it. He didn't believe that a lone assassin, Lee Harvey Oswald, acted alone killing JFK. In public, Johnson supported the Vietnam War. On the telephone, he admitted his doubts.
他在电话里比在公开场合更诚实。公开场合中，约翰逊说他相信沃伦委员会的调查报告。而在电话里，他承认他不相信。他不相信李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德(Lee Harvey Oswald)是独自刺杀肯尼迪的孤狼刺客。公开场合中，约翰逊支持越战。而在电话里，他承认了自己的怀疑。
I'll tell you, the more I just stayed awake last night thinking about this thing, the more I think of it, I don't know what in the hell-- It looks like, to me, we're getting into another Korea. And it just worries the hell out of me. I don't see what we can ever hope to get out of there with once we're committed.
我跟你说，昨晚我越是躺着想这件事，就越觉得，我不知道到底……在我看来，我们正陷入另一场朝鲜战争。这让我担心极了。一旦我们卷入其中，我不知道我们还能指望怎么脱身。
He's talking to National Security Advisor McGeorge Bundy.
他正在和国家安全顾问麦乔治·邦迪(McGeorge Bundy)谈话。
I don't think it's worth fighting for. And I don't think we can get out. And it's just the biggest damn mess--
我不认为这值得一战。我不认为我们能脱身。这简直是天大的烂摊子——
It is. It's an awful mess.
确实。这是一个糟糕的烂摊子。
I look at this sergeant of mine this morning. He's got six little old kids over there. And he's getting out my things and bringing me in my night reading and all that kind of stuff. And I just thought about ordering all those kids in there. And what in the hell am I ordering him out there for?
今天早上我看着我的那个军士。他在那边有六个小孩。他帮我整理东西，带给我夜间读物之类的东西。我刚才就在想，我要命令所有那些孩子去那里。我到底是为了什么才命令他去那里的？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[干扰声]
What the hell is Vietnam worth to me? What is Laos worth to me? What is it worth to this country? Now, of course, if you start running the communists, they may just chase you right into your own kitchen.
越南对我来说到底有什么意义？老挝对我来说有什么意义？这对这个国家有什么意义？当然，如果你开始对付共产主义者，他们可能会把你一直追到你自己的厨房里。
Yep, that's the trouble. And that is what the rest of that half of the world is going to think if this thing comes apart on us. That's the dilemma. That's exactly the dilemma.
是啊，这就是麻烦所在。如果这件事情在我们手上搞砸了，世界上另一半国家的人都会这么想。这就是两难境地。这正是两难境地。
But everybody I talk to that's got any sense in there, they just says, "Oh, my god, please [UNINTELLIGIBLE]" But it's damned easy to get in a war, but it's going to be awfully hard to ever extricate yourself if you get in.
但我谈过的所有明白人都说：“哦，天哪，求你了[听不清]”。但卷入战争是再容易不过了，如果你陷进去，想脱身可就难上加难了。
It's very easy. I'm very sensitive to the fact that people who are having trouble with--
非常容易。我非常敏感地意识到，那些在……方面有困难的人。
On the telephone, we are who we truly are, some of the time, anyway. Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, telephone stories, what we reveal about ourselves on the phone that we do not reveal any other way.
在电话里，我们有时会表现出真实的一面。好了，来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》(This American Life)。我是艾拉·格拉斯(Ira Glass)。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是电话故事，关于我们在电话里揭示出的、而在其他任何方式下都不会揭示的自我。
Act One, When the Wall Came Tumbling Down, the story of a teenager, illegal drug use, lying, stealing, and a kid's life completely changed when he heard how he sounded on the phone. Act Two, When Your Telephone is Your Medium. Sure, you can try to get your pop songs onto records, onto the radio, onto MTV. But what if your medium of choice is the telephone? We offer a case example, the band They Might Be Giants. Act Three, Telephone as History, moments from a normal human life saved on answering machine. Stay with us.
第一幕，当墙倒塌时，讲述了一个青少年的故事，涉及非法药物使用、撒谎、偷窃，以及一个孩子在听到自己在电话里的声音后，生活发生了彻底的改变。第二幕，当电话成为你的媒介。当然，你可以尝试把流行歌曲录成唱片，放到电台，放到MTV上。但如果你选择的媒介是电话呢？我们提供一个案例，乐队“他们可能是巨人”(They Might Be Giants)。第三幕，电话作为历史，记录在答录机里的普通人生活时刻。请继续收听。
Act One. Let's forget telephone numbers for a moment, and let's start with a zip code, 90210. That's where this story takes place, literally. Joshua was a student at Beverly Hills High School. Kids there had a lot of money, did a lot of drugs. And he started doing them, too, in a pretty serious way.
第一幕。让我们暂时忘掉电话号码，从一个邮政编码开始，90210。这就是这个故事发生的地方，字面意义上的。约书亚(Joshua)是贝弗利山高中的一名学生。那里的孩子很有钱，吸毒成风。他也开始以一种相当严重的方式吸毒。
I failed English. I failed PE, even, which is difficult to do, unless you're running off getting stoned whenever you're supposed to be running around the track. And I just did whatever I wanted to do, whenever I wanted to do it.
我英语不及格。我甚至连体育都不及格，这很难做到，除非你本该在操场上跑步时却跑去嗑药了。我只是想做什么就做什么，想什么时候做就什么时候做。
I stole money from my parents kind of regularly to finance my marijuana habit. I did break into my parents' tenants', basically, house a few times, mostly to steal drugs, not money. But that was the only stealing that I did. I never actually stole anything except for drugs and money. And the money, I only stole from my parents.
我经常从父母那里偷钱来供我的大麻瘾。我基本上闯入过我父母的房客家里几次，主要是为了偷药，而不是钱。但那是我做的唯一的偷窃行为。我从来没偷过除了毒品和钱以外的任何东西。至于钱，我只从我父母那里偷。
Well, I noticed my dad started to punish me for things that I hadn't done, or at least things that he couldn't have possibly known that I had done. And I would have a great weekend planned. For instance, we were going to go out and do whatever sorts of craziness would come up. Maybe we'll go take some LSD or something like that, or mushrooms. And my dad would ground me the day before for no particular reason. And it was very strange. The timing was uncanny.
嗯，我发现我爸爸开始因为我没做过的事情，或者至少是他不可能知道我做过的事情来惩罚我。我本计划好了一个很棒的周末。例如，我们打算出去做各种疯狂的事情。也许我们会去吃点LSD（迷幻药）之类的，或者蘑菇。而我爸爸在前一天无缘无故地禁我的足。这很奇怪。时间点诡异得令人不可思议。
And one day, he was driving me down to school, as he did every morning. And on the way to school, he told me that the administration of Beverly had contacted him and that they had narcs in the school that were posing as students. And they were going to run a sweep of the school and basically bust everyone who was involved in this. So he told me that the administration had contacted him because they knew that I was involved in this whole faction of bad eggs. And they also knew that I was not a dealer. Basically, they were calling him to warn him to basically give me a chance to get out of the bust. So he told me I'd better get it together because it's going to happen very soon.
有一天，他像往常一样每天早上开车送我去学校。在去学校的路上，他告诉我，贝弗利的校方联系了他，说学校里有缉毒警察假扮成学生。他们打算在学校进行一次大搜查，基本上要把所有参与的人都抓起来。所以他告诉我，校方联系他是因为他们知道我参与了这一伙害群之马。他们也知道我不是毒贩。基本上，他们打电话给他是在警告他，好给我一个逃避抓捕的机会。所以他告诉我，最好收敛一点，因为很快就会发生。
And then, in the same conversation, he started naming all of the names of the kids that were involved. And they were names that there was no way he could know. And so the story was very credible the way it was laid out. And I believed it 100%. And I went to school that day, I remember, and of course, I told all of my friends that there was going to be this major bust happening at Beverly Hills High School very soon. And so everybody better quickly go undercover. And people became much more careful.
然后，在同一个谈话中，他开始列举所有参与孩子的名字。那些名字是他不可能知道的。所以这个故事说得头头是道，非常可信。我百分之百相信了。我记得那天我去学校，当然，我告诉了我所有的朋友，贝弗利山高中很快会发生一次大搜查。所以大家最好赶快潜伏起来。人们变得谨慎多了。
About a month later, I was in the backyard. And there had been a windstorm the night before, a really big wind. And a panel on the side of the house had come off. And I was in the backyard with my friend. And we were smoking a joint like we always did. Every day after school, we would come home and smoke a joint. And my friend noticed this panel down.
大约一个月后，我在后院。前一天晚上有一场风暴，风很大。房子侧面的一个嵌板掉了下来。我和我的朋友在后院。我们像往常一样在抽大麻烟。每天放学后，我们都会回家抽一支。我朋友注意到了这个掉下来的嵌板。
I'll never forget this one, actually. He said, "Dude, what is this? Come here, dude. And I'm standing on the other side of the backyard, smoking a joint, looking at the trees. And he's like, "Come here, dude." I walked over. He's like, "Look at this." And it didn't dawn on me. I looked at it, and I was like, "What is it? Strange piece of machinery inside of wall." It made no sense to me whatsoever. And he looked at me. He said, "Dude, your parents are taping your calls." And that meant that dad knew everything. No wonder he was grounding me at such crucial moments in my party life.
说实话，我永远忘不了这一次。他说：“伙计，这是什么？过来，伙计。”我站在后院的另一边，抽着烟，看着树。他喊：“过来，伙计。”我走过去。他说：“看这个。”我还没反应过来。我看着它，心想：“这是什么？墙里有奇怪的机械。”我完全看不懂。他看着我说：“伙计，你父母在监听你的电话。”这意味着我爸知道了一切。难怪他在我派对生活的关键时刻给我禁足。
I'm getting some buds and some coke delivered here tonight.
我今晚在这儿要弄点嫩芽（大麻）和可卡因。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, so listen, if you guys want to come, just call me before you come. Well, you can come over here if you want.
是啊，所以听着，如果你们想来，来之前先打电话给我。嗯，如果你们想的话，可以来我这儿。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Because they're going out, so--
是啊。因为他们要出门了，所以——
You don't have five grams.
你没有五克。
Dude, what's the big deal?
伙计，这有什么大不了的？
I'm bumming hard.
我非常沮丧。
You're getting an eighth for $25 and a gram.
你花25美元能买到八分之一盎司再加一克。
All right, I guess I can--
好吧，我想我可以——
Is that cool?
这样行吗？
An eighth for $25 and a gram for $10?
八分之一盎司25美元，一克10美元？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
All right.
好吧。
The only weed he can get you is the same weed I can get you. But dude, it's [BLEEP].
他能给你的唯一大麻和我能给你的是一样的。但伙计，那是[脏话]。
When I saw the tape recorder, it was disbelief. I was in a state of disbelief. Pure shock.
当我看到录音机时，我简直不敢相信。我处于一种难以置信的状态。纯粹的震惊。
This is what happened. My son was a very good student. All of a sudden, his grades started collapsing. His school things started collapsing. He started acting like a complete fool. Now, he's ready to graduate from Beverly High. And his attitude is becoming a total [BLEEP] box. He's becoming an asshole everywhere.
事情是这样的。我儿子以前是个非常优秀的学生。突然间，他的成绩开始一落千丈。他的学校生活开始崩溃。他开始表现得像个十足的傻瓜。现在，他准备从贝弗利高中毕业了。他的态度变得像个彻底的[脏话]。他变得到处都是混蛋。
So I thought, you know, the only way I can figure out what's happening with him is-- because he comes home every day and he's alone a long time at home, got a lot of time on the phone. Right? So I figure, well, what I'll do is that I'll tape record his phone calls.
所以我想，你知道，我能弄清楚他发生了什么事的唯一方法是——因为他每天回家后都有很长一段时间独自在家，他在电话上花了很多时间。对吧？所以我心想，好吧，我要做的就是录下他的电话。
So I went to a lot of people who knew about this kind of stuff. And I said, how can I do this? They said, well, what you have to do is get a voice-activated tape recorder. And you have to hook it up to the phone. So I removed an outside wall of my house, which was a bunch of boards. Removed it, built it into one situation where I could clamp it back on with magnets. So I could take it off and put it back on. I put this tape recorder inside the wall outside of my kitchen. The wire went down, and then it went through the wall into the tape recorder. I figured, nobody's ever going to notice that because it's way down on the bottom, way under everything. And who's going to look for the goddamn wire where the phone goes?
所以我找了很多了解这类事情的人。我说，我该怎么做？他们说，好吧，你得买一个声控录音机。你得把它连接到电话上。所以我拆掉了房子的一面外墙，那是一堆木板。拆掉后，把它建成一个可以用磁铁重新扣上的状态。所以我可以把它取下来再装回去。我把这台录音机放在厨房外面的墙里。电线向下走，然后穿过墙进入录音机。我想，没人会注意到这一点，因为它在最下面，在所有东西的最底下。谁会去寻找电话线路经过的地方那该死的电线呢？
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
Working. Working.
工作。工作。
[CLICK CLICK CLICK]
[咔哒 咔哒 咔哒]
Unbelievable. I can't believe that this is going on. It was a multiple emotional cascade because on the one hand, I'm being incredibly violated by my father.
难以置信。我不敢相信这正在发生。这是一个多重的情感冲击，因为一方面，我被我父亲极大地侵犯了。
But we gave him whatever we could give him, everything we could possibly give him. And then, I felt real violated by the fact that he thought that was nothing. What meant something to him was that he wanted to do these things that he wanted to do. He wanted to be with these people he wanted to be with.
但我们给了他我们能给的一切，所有我们可能给他的一切。然后，我感到被他认为那是理所当然的事实深深地冒犯了。对他来说意味着什么的是，他想做他想做的事情。他想和他想在一起的这些人在一起。
Dad, I went home today during fifth mod.
爸，我今天第五节课去过家里。
Yeah?
是吗？
You turned my room upside down, didn't you?
你把我的房间翻了个底朝天，对吧？
All I know is that there was a note on our front door from Annie.
我只知道前门上有一张安妮留的字条。
That said?
上面写的？
That said someone has been in her apartment again, taking certain things.
上面写着有人又进了她的公寓，拿走了一些东西。
What? What was missing?
什么？丢了什么？
Some drugs.
一些毒品。
There was a note on it--
上面有一张字条——
Have you been going into Annie's again?
你是不是又进安妮的公寓了？
No. I just got that one bud from my friend, and that's all.
没有。我只是从我朋友那儿拿了那一点点大麻，仅此而已。
I want to know, did you go in her apartment again?
我想知道，你是不是又进了她的公寓？
Dad, I can't get in her apartment.
爸，我进不去她的公寓。
I want to know, did you go in her apartment?
我想知道，你是不是进了她的公寓？
Yes. And I took one minute bud. I didn't take drugs. I took one small bud, and I left.
是的。我拿了一点点嫩芽。我没拿毒品。我拿了一小点嫩芽，然后就走了。
OK, you go to work. But tonight, I want to have a little discussion with you, because I'm going to have to try to find out where you're coming from, and--
好吧，你去工作吧。但今晚，我想和你谈谈，因为我得试着找出你的想法，并且——
Dad, I'm not coming--
爸，我没想——
I just  think I've got you figured out when something else happens.
我以为我已经摸透你了，结果又发生了别的事。
No, Dad. No. [BLEEP]
不，爸。不。[脏话]
He never came to my work during the day. When he was going to school, never. He'd start coming to my work at lunchtime. And he would say, "Hey, I just came over to see if you guys needed any help or had anything I could do or whatever." And then he'd leave. And there'd be like $100, $200 missing from the drawer.
他白天从不来我工作的地方。他在上学的时候，从不来。他开始在午餐时间来我工作的地方。他会说：“嘿，我只是来看看你们需不需要什么帮忙，或者有什么我可以做的，什么的。”然后他就走了。抽屉里就会少个100、200美元。
[BLEEP]. I hope Scott didn't score that stuff.
[脏话]。我希望斯科特没搞到那些东西。
Why?
为什么？
Because I want my money back.
因为我想把钱拿回来。
Because you want to buy blow, or you just don't want to--
因为你想买可卡因，还是你只是不想——
No, I have to give that $100 back to my dad.
不，我得把那100美元还给我爸。
He knows?
他知道吗？
Yep.
是的。
How'd he find out?
他是怎么发现的？
I don't know.
我不知道。
The tapes were horrible, redundant, stupid, dull.
这些磁带非常可怕、冗长、愚蠢、乏味。
He goes, "Check this out." And he just hit the accelerator, and the thing took off, man. It was so fast. It's so rad.
他说：“看看这个。”然后他猛踩油门，那车就冲出去了，伙计。太快了。太狂了。
You know, a teenager gets on the phone, they stay on the phone for a long time. Hours. I would come home, and I would have to listen to three, four hours of tape of him on the phone, saying nothing. I mean dribble, like, "Hey, hey, man. What's up? What are you going to do?" "Hey, what are you going to do?"
你知道，一个青少年打电话，他们会打很久。几个小时。我回家后，不得不听他三四个小时的电话录音，什么内容都没有。我的意思是胡言乱语，就像，“嘿，嘿，伙计。怎么样？你要做什么？”“嘿，你要做什么？”
Hello?
喂？
Hey.
嘿。
What's happening?
在干嘛呢？
Not much. How was Palm Springs?
没什么。棕榈泉之行怎么样？
All right.
还可以。
Really?
真的吗？
But the interesting part was that things would come around, like, what are we going to do tomorrow? Hey, why don't we do some coke? Why don't we do some-- But what I tried to do was that, whenever I heard something on this tape that was a direction he was going to go in, I would say, "Could you help me at my shop tomorrow at 4 o'clock? I really need you." And he'd go, "Oh, well, I'm busy." And I'd say, "I don't care how busy you are. I really need you. This is important." And he would shut off the plans. And he would come and help me. So what I tried to do by listening to the tapes was to redirect whatever he was going to do. And I did that. And it worked. It worked.
但有趣的部分是，事情会转到，比如，我们明天要做什么？嘿，我们要不要弄点可卡因？我们要不要做些……但我试着做的是，每当我在磁带里听到他要走的路线时，我就会说：“你明天4点能帮我店里的忙吗？我真的需要你。”他会说：“哦，我忙着呢。”我会说：“我不管你有多忙。我真的需要你。这很重要。”他就会打消那些计划。他就会来帮我。所以我通过听这些磁带试着去重定向他要做的事情。我做了。而且奏效了。奏效了。
This doesn't have anything to do with parents, man. We're talking serious matters.
这和父母没关系，伙计。我们在谈论正经事。
Dude, what happened?
伙计，发生什么事了？
Like Beverly Hills Police Department.
比如贝弗利山警察局。
Dude, why? I'm not going to tell anybody, don't worry.
伙计，为什么？我不会告诉任何人的，别担心。
Because of my known--
因为我已知的——
Involvement?
参与？
--involvement with drugs at Beverly Hills High School. They've been calling my dad and asking him if he's ever-- You know what they said to my dad?
——参与贝弗利山高中的毒品活动。他们一直在打电话给我爸，问他是否曾经……你知道他们对我爸说了什么吗？
What?
什么？
My dad named so many names to me that I've never even said to him.
我爸列举了这么多我甚至从来没对他提起过的名字。
Dude man, they've probably been following you.
伙计，他们可能一直在跟踪你。
Dude, it's everybody. They've got about 50 undercover narcs at my school now.
伙计，是所有人。他们现在学校里大约有50名卧底缉毒警。
What you should do is just stop abruptly.
你应该做的是立刻停止。
That's what I have--
我必须——
Dude, don't even talk to those people.
伙计，甚至别和那些人说话。
I have been. I've fully just stopped.
我一直在做。我已经彻底停止了。
There was no way I could possibly confront him and have a truthful situation come out of it. No. He would never admit that to me. Never.
我不可能去和他对质并得到一个真实的局面。不。他永远不会向我承认这一点。永远不会。
Seeing the tape recorder made me realize, wow, what am I going to do? What's the way out of this? Because I was a conniver. I was going to come up with the best solution to escape. So after some thought, I decided that the best road of action would be to continue my lifestyle, of course, while simultaneously becoming perfect on the telephone. In other words, I would just clean up my act on the phone.
看到录音机让我意识到，哇，我该怎么办？出路是什么？因为我是一个密谋者。我想出了逃避的最佳方案。所以深思熟虑后，我决定最好的行动方针是继续我的生活方式，同时在电话里变得完美。换句话说，我只是要在电话里洗心革面。
You're quitting.
你要戒了？
I swear. That's it. It's caused me too much trouble.
我发誓。就是这样。它给我带来了太多的麻烦。
Aren't you going to miss it?
你不会怀念它吗？
No way. Fortunately, pot is one of those things that you like outgrow, kind of. It's not like you mature out of it, but you get bored of it.
不可能。幸运的是，大麻是你那种会随着成长而放弃的东西。并不是你成熟了就戒掉了，而是你对它感到厌倦了。
Yeah, did you get the acid?
是啊，你拿到迷幻药了吗？
No, dude.
没有，伙计。
When do you get it?
你什么时候拿到？
I'm not going to do it, dude. I'll get it for you. But I'm not going to do it.
我不会去碰它的，伙计。我会帮你弄到。但我不会碰它。
You're not going to do it?
你不打算碰它？
No.
不。
Why? What's wrong with you, man? What are you on? What are you on?
为什么？你怎么了，伙计？你在嗑什么？你在嗑什么？
I'm not on anything. I'm just tired. Dude, I'm going straight, man. I'm quitting.
我什么都没嗑。我只是累了。伙计，我要改邪归正了，伙计。我要戒了。
OK, well, I want my [BLEEP].
好吧，那我想要我的[脏话]。
Now, all I have to do is regain the respect of my father.
现在，我唯一要做的就是重新赢得父亲的尊重。
Well, that went on for about a month. It went on for about a month of me being perfect on the telephone. And it worked. He stopped busting me at crucial moments. I was able to go out and do everything I wanted to. I alerted everyone at Beverly that, in fact, there wasn't going to be a sweep, that it was all part of this scandal perpetrated by my father, and much to their relief. And so that went on for about a month, of this counter espionage, I guess you would have to call it. And it worked.
好吧，这持续了大约一个月。我完美地打了一个月的电话。而且奏效了。他不再在关键时刻抓我了。我能够出去做我想做的一切了。我通知了贝弗利的所有人，事实上，并没有什么大搜查，那全是我父亲策划的一场闹剧，他们听了都如释重负。所以在那一个月里，我一直在进行反间谍活动，我想你只能这么称呼它。而且奏效了。
It had gotten to the point of deception upon deception upon deception, multiple lies on both sides. So I was very disturbed by the fact that my relationship with my father had so apparently deteriorated. My father means a lot to me. And he did then, and he always has. And I realized the degree to which we had grown apart, basically.
这已经到了欺骗之上再加欺骗，双方都有多重谎言的地步。所以我非常不安，因为我与父亲的关系显然恶化到了这种程度。我父亲对我意义重大。当时是这样，一直以来都是这样。我意识到我们基本上已经疏远到了什么地步。
So one night, I went out with a couple of friends of mine. And we took some LSD, some very strong LSD that we had bought down in Hollywood from a dealer who was down there at that time, a guy by the name of Strange, was his name, actually. He was an albino. I think he's dead now. But anyway, in the throes of this LSD realization, enlightenment, that I was going through, I realized that the situation with my father was completely unacceptable. And it had to be remedied right away. I had to do something immediately about it.
所以有一天晚上，我和几个朋友出去了。我们吃了一些LSD，一些非常强的LSD，是我们从好莱坞的一个毒贩那里买的，当时在那儿的一个家伙，名字叫“陌生人”(Strange)，事实上，他是个白化病人。我想他现在可能死了。但无论如何，在这种LSD实现的狂喜、顿悟中，我意识到与父亲的情况是完全不可接受的。必须立即补救。我必须立刻对此做点什么。
So I told my two poor friends, who were also right in the middle of their trip, getting involved in whatever was going on in their minds. I said, "We have to go to my house. We have to go home right now." So we drove here. And Dad was having a party. There was a party going on. And I walked into the party rather nonchalantly. And I looked at my father with a very serious look. And I said, "I have to talk to you about something." So we walked outside to the yard out front. And I said, basically, "Dad, I know you're taping my calls. And I know you've been taping my calls."
所以我告诉我的两个可怜的朋友，他们也正处于药效之中，沉浸在他们脑子里发生的任何事情中。我说：“我们得回家。我们现在必须回家。”所以我们开车回到了这里。爸爸在开派对。正在举行派对。我相当漫不经心地走进了派对。我用非常严肃的眼神看着父亲。我说：“我必须和你谈点事。”所以我们走到前面的院子里。我说，基本上，“爸，我知道你在录我的电话。而且我知道你一直在录我的电话。”
It was such a strange sort of accusation I was making, once again, because simultaneously, I was admitting to him that I knew that he knew everything that was going on. So on the one hand, I'm saying, "Dad, how could you be so horrible as to invade my privacy like this?" while simultaneously realizing that he knew that I had been stealing money from him to support my pot habits. And he said, "You're right, I'm taping your calls. I've been doing it for quite a while, as a matter of fact. And I'm not going to do it anymore. I'm not going to tape your telephone calls anymore." He said, "There's something you don't know yet, but I'll tell you now. And perhaps you will not understand what I'm saying. But you think that because I'm your father and I'm in this role of the disciplinarian, that it's between you and I. What you haven't realized yet is that your actions have far more impact on your own life than they will on mine. I've already made my life. You have to make your life. And you don't know it yet." He said, "I'm going to take the tape recorder out tomorrow."
这是一种很奇怪的指责，再一次，因为与此同时，我向他承认我知道他知道正在发生的一切。所以一方面，我说：“爸，你怎么能这么恶劣，这样侵犯我的隐私？”同时意识到他知道我一直偷他的钱来维持我的大麻瘾。他说：“你说得对，我在录你的电话。事实上，我已经录了有一段时间了。我不会再这样做了。我不会再录你的电话了。”他说：“有件事你还不知道，但我现在告诉你。也许你不会明白我在说什么。但你认为因为我是你的父亲，我扮演的是纪律管教者的角色，所以这是你我之间的问题。你还没意识到的是，你的行为对你自己生活的影响要远大于对我的影响。我已经过完了我的生活。你必须创造你的生活。而你还不知道这一点。”他说：“我明天会把录音机拿走。我只想要你做一件事。”我说：“什么？”他说：“我大概有40盘关于你的90分钟录音带。我要把它们给你。我希望你听听它们。这就是我的全部要求。没有惩罚。这一切结束了。这一章结束了。但这些磁带现在属于你了。”
And I was waiting for the punishment at this point, because there must be some amazing punishment coming down. Because he knew everything. Military school, or what's he going to do? He said, "I'll take the tape recorder out tomorrow. And there's only one thing I want you to do." And I said, "What?" And he said, "I have about 40 tapes, about 40 90-minute tapes of you. I'm going to give them to you. And I want you to listen to them. And that's all I ask. No punishment. This is over. This chapter is over. But the tapes are now yours."
我当时在等着惩罚，因为肯定会有某种惊人的惩罚降临。因为他什么都知道。军校，或者他打算怎么做？他说：“我明天会把录音机拿走。我只想要你做一件事。”我说：“什么？”他说：“我大概有40盘关于你的90分钟录音带。我要把它们给你。我希望你听听它们。这就是我的全部要求。没有惩罚。这一切结束了。这一章结束了。但这些磁带现在属于你了。”
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
Hello?
喂？
Hi. What's the matter?
嗨。怎么了？
Nothing.
没什么。
All right, well, you don't have to talk.
好吧，你没必要非得说话。
It was embarrassing. I was embarrassing myself, listening to myself.
那很尴尬。我在听自己的时候，感到自己很丢脸。
Can I ask you something?
我可以问你一件事吗？
What's that?
什么事？
Are you awake enough to answer?
你醒着能回答吗？
Yeah, I think I can, if I try real hard.
是啊，我想如果我努力尝试的话，我可以。
I get the feeling that you've changed the way you feel about me. And I don't like that.
我感觉你对我改变了看法。我不喜欢那样。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
I mean, obviously, there's nothing I can do.
我的意思是，显然，我什么都做不了。
Nah, nah, nah.
不，不，不。
Nah, nah, what?
不，不，什么？
I don't know what you're talking about.
我不知道你在说什么。
Well, then, how come you haven't called me in so long?
那，为什么你这么久没给我打电话了？
I've been busy.
我一直很忙。
Well, that's really the truth?
那真的是实话吗？
Yeah, I hope so.
是啊，我希望是。
It was about a week afterwards, and I couldn't really listen to them. I had a very hard time listening to them. In a way, it was kind of surrealistic because I had no idea what I sounded like. And I didn't like what I sounded like at all. I thought I sounded really kind of unkind, self-serving, mean, basically, and totally uncaring.
那大约是一周后，我真的听不下去。我听它们听得很吃力。某种程度上，这有点超现实，因为我根本不知道自己的声音听起来是什么样。我一点也不喜欢自己的声音。我觉得自己听起来真的很刻薄、自私、卑鄙，而且完全不关心别人。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, dude.
嘿，伙计。
Hey.
嘿。
What's happening?
在干嘛呢？
Not much.
没干嘛。
Do you have any finals tomorrow?
你明天有期末考试吗？
Yeah.
有。
What?
什么？
English.
英语。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
I still don't have any.
我还一个都没有呢。
I'm kind of busy right now.
我现在有点忙。
I can tell. It sounds like people are in the background.
我看得出来。听起来背景里有人。
They are.
是有人。
Parental units?
父母单位的人？
Huh?
哈？
Parental units?
父母单位的人？
No, no, no. Friend units.
不，不，不。朋友单位的。
Oh, that sounds radical.
哦，听起来很激进。
Yeah, it is. Bye.
是啊，是挺激进的。拜。
Great.
太棒了。
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
I was very self-centered and egotistical and uncaring of other people. It was about me. I was the star of my own stage. And everybody else could basically go to hell, as far as I was concerned. I had never realized that aspect of my personality. I didn't know how mean, in that sense, I had gotten.
我是个非常以自我为中心、利己、且不关心别人的人。一切都是关于我。我是我自己舞台上的明星。至于其他人，只要我关心，他们基本上可以去死。我从未意识到我人格中的那一面。我不知道在那方面我变得有多刻薄。
Hello?
喂？
Hello, is it possible for me to speak with Mr. Or Mrs. O'Hara?
喂，请问我可以和奥哈拉先生或太太通话吗？
No.
不能。
Hello?
喂？
May I speak with  Novella?
我可以和诺薇拉(Novella)通话吗？
What?
什么？
Novella.
诺薇拉。
Who is this?
你是哪位？
My name is Crawford. I'm with the VFW.
我叫克劳福德(Crawford)。我是海外战争退伍军人协会(VFW)的。
What is it in regards to?
请问有什么事？
The National Veteran Wheelchair Games.
全国退伍军人轮椅运动会。
Well, can I take a message for her?
那，我可以帮她带个口信吗？
No, I'll call back later.
不，我晚点再打来。
Well, listen. Hello?
那，听着。喂？
Yes?
喂？
She's dead.
她死了。
Oh, I see.
哦，明白了。
So, you know, I think-- What is it in regards to? Do you owe us some money?
所以，你知道，我想——请问有什么事？你欠我们钱吗？
No, we were selling and delivering heavy-duty plastic trash bags to raise funds.
不，我们在卖和运送重型塑料垃圾袋以筹集资金。
So you wanted money.
所以你是要钱。
And I remember listening to that on the tapes subsequently. And again, it was just like, my god, I'm a monster. This is outrageous. Look at the way I'm treating people. Because I don't feel that way, and I'm not that type of person. But at the time, I was, very much. And I didn't know it. I didn't know how little I valued friendship or other people's feelings.
我记得后来在录音带里听到了那一幕。我再一次感到，我的天，我是个怪物。这太离谱了。看看我对待别人的方式。因为我不觉得那是我，我不是那种人。但在当时，我的确就是那样。我不知道这一点。我不知道我有多么轻视友谊或他人的感受。
Then we went to this dance club, and we just met some people. There was these girls. But we weren't going to scam off them. We were just friends.
然后我们去了这家舞厅，我们就认识了一些人。有这些女孩。但我们不是要去骗她们。我们只是朋友。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
We waited for like a half hour to get our table--
我们等了大约半小时才得到我们的桌子——
And did you scam off them?
那你们骗了她们吗？
What?
什么？
Did you scam them? Or no?
你们骗她们了吗？还是没有？
No.
没有。
They were just nice?
她们只是很好？
Yeah. They were just like-- It was just conversation. It was--
是啊。她们只是……这只是对话。这只是——
Bleh. Dude, if I was there, that wouldn't have happened. We would've done some [BLEEP].
呸。伙计，如果我在那儿，那就不会发生。我们会做些[脏话]。
It took me about five or six years before I managed to listen to all of them. My course of life changed dramatically because of that event. And a lot changed. I still partied. But I put it back, as far as the importance, where it was on the hierarchy. It was like smoking pot ceased to be number one. And lying, deceiving, cheating, stealing, all of that, I just stopped. Stopped it all.
我花了大约五六年时间才把它们听完。我的生活轨迹因为那件事发生了巨大的改变。很多事情都变了。我还是去派对。但我把它的重要性放回了它在层次结构中应有的位置。就像吸食大麻不再是头等大事了。撒谎、欺骗、作弊、偷窃，所有这些，我全都停了。全部停了。
It was amazing. He understood the entire thing that he was doing that was so-- and believe me, it was stupid.
这太神奇了。他理解了他所做的那整件事，那真的很……相信我，真的很愚蠢。
Because I never had the opportunity to hear myself. I didn't know. I didn't know what I was doing. The tone of voice of my quote-quote "friends"-- I could hear in their voice on the tapes, pain because of my actions and my uncaring. That was an awakening.
因为我从来没有机会听到我自己。我不知道。我不知道我在做什么。那些所谓的“朋友”的语调——我能从磁带里的声音中听到因为我的行为和漠不关心而产生的痛苦。那是一次觉醒。
I haven't heard from you for a while. Ouch.
我已经很久没听到你的消息了。哎哟。
I haven't heard from you for a while.
我已经很久没听到你的消息了。
Yes, you have.
不对，你听到了。
Oh yeah, when?
哦，是吗，什么时候？
Last time we talked, I called you.
上次我们通话时，我打给了你。
Oh, you mean you actually keep track?
哦，你是说你真的有在记录？
No, I just remember that.
不，我只是记得那个。
Really?
真的吗？
I became the watcher of myself while I was acting simultaneously. And I still do that to this day. I see, I'm intensely aware of my effect on other people. That's one thing that definitely came out. It's like I know what other people are feeling about me.
我在行动的同时成为了自己的观察者。时至今日我依然这样做。我看到了，我非常清楚自己对他人的影响。这是绝对产生的影响之一。就像我知道别人对我有什么感觉。
That was an interesting look you gave me today.
你今天看我的那个眼神很有意思。
Oh. Ha. I know.
哦。哈。我知道。
So what's the problem with you? What are you pissed off at me for?
所以你有什么问题？你因为什么生我的气？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Is is that time of the month again?
是不是又到了每个月的那几天？
No. [INAUDIBLE]
不是。[听不清]
Well, then, what's wrong?
那，怎么了？
Well, I guess the basic thing is I don't like your fluctuation in attention towards me.
嗯，我想最基本的事情是我不喜欢你对我的关注度忽高忽低。
What are you talking about? If I'm not going somewhere, if I have not got a set place that I am off to-- and I'm probably usually late-- then I stop and talk to you.
你在说什么？如果我不是要去某个地方，如果我没有设定好我要去的地方——而且我通常总是迟到——那我就会停下来和你聊天。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And well, forget it then. [BLEEP].
那好吧，算了。[脏话]。
Wait. Hold on. Mom?
等等。等一下。妈？
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
It was valuable, very valuable, to be able to witness myself in that way, although painful. I got to see myself. It's a rare gift, in a way, to be able to see yourself from the outside, from an objective point of view. I think it's probably always going to be difficult to watch yourself. Given an opportunity, I think most people would probably not want to see themselves that clearly.
能够以那种方式见证自己非常有价值，虽然很痛苦。我得以看见自己。从某种意义上说，能从外部、从客观的角度看待自己，是一种罕见的礼物。我想注视自己可能永远是件困难的事。如果有机会，我想大多数人可能不想把自己看得那么清楚。
Joshua and his father talked to Dave Kestenbaum, who's a writer for Science magazine, and to Julie Snyder.
约书亚和他父亲接受了《科学》杂志撰稿人戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆(Dave Kestenbaum)和朱莉·斯奈德(Julie Snyder)的采访。
[MUSIC - "I'VE GOT A NEW HOME" BY PILGRIM TRAVELERS]
[音乐 - “我有一个新家”，朝圣者旅行者乐队]
Coming up, telephone as an artistic medium, telephone as muse. What a songwriter can learn from the telephone. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，电话作为艺术媒介，电话作为缪斯。词曲作家能从电话里学到什么。一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of reporters and writers and performers to tackle that theme. Today's show, things we learn on the phone, who we are on the phone, things we find on the phone that we can not find anywhere else. We have arrived at Act Two of our program, When the Telephone is Your Medium.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种记者、作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，我们在电话里学到的东西，我们在电话里的样子，我们在电话里找到的而在其他地方找不到的东西。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕，当电话成为你的媒介。
Well, the band They Might Be Giants do not have a song on every episode of This American Life . But I have to say, most weeks, at some point, contributing editor Sarah Vowell suggests a song of theirs that might work in the show. And that's because they are not only prolific. More than other bands, they write about an astonishing number of things in this surprising, funny way.
好吧，乐队“他们可能是巨人”并没有在《美国生活》的每一集里都有一首歌。但我必须说，大多数周，在某个时候，特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔(Sarah Vowell)都会建议一首他们的歌，觉得可能适合节目。这是因为他们不仅多产，而且比其他乐队更以令人惊奇的、有趣的方式撰写数量惊人的事物。
Also, although they are an actual pop band with actual pop hits, it is hard to think of any band in the last 20 years with more inventive arrangements. They just have this sound, this sense of how different instruments go together. They bring pre-rock instruments into the rock universe in this completely charming way. John Linnell of They Might Be Giants, he is the Keith Richards of the bass clarinet.
此外，虽然他们是一支真正的流行乐队，有着真正的流行热曲，但很难想到过去20年里有哪支乐队拥有比他们更具创造性的编曲。他们就是有这种声音，这种对不同乐器如何搭配在一起的感知。他们以一种完全迷人的方式将前摇滚时代的乐器带入了摇滚宇宙。“他们可能是巨人”的约翰·林内尔(John Linnell)，他是低音单簧管界的基思·理查兹(Keith Richards)。
And at the heart of their artistic practices-- you know we have a theme to the show every week. We have a theme to this show. And you know what the theme is. So you know where I'm going with this-- At the heart of their artistic practice is the telephone. It was, anyway. Still sort of is. Sarah Vowell visited them in Brooklyn.
在他们艺术实践的核心——你知道我们每周节目都有一个主题。我们有这个节目的主题。你知道主题是什么。所以你明白我的意思了——他们艺术实践的核心是电话。反正曾经是。现在某种程度上依然是。莎拉·沃威尔在布鲁克林拜访了他们。
What if art cost a quarter a pop? What if it offered home delivery? What if it was short, but sweet? What if art was just a phone call away?
如果艺术每次只需25美分呢？如果它提供送货上门呢？如果它简短而甜蜜呢？如果艺术只需一个电话就能触及呢？
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello, everybody. This is John of They Might Be Giants. Thank you for calling our Dial-a-Song service. We hope you like it, hope it sounds good over your phone. Thank you for calling. Call back anytime.
大家好。这里是“他们可能是巨人”的约翰。感谢您致电我们的“拨号歌曲”(Dial-a-Song)服务。希望您喜欢，希望它在您的电话里听起来不错。感谢您的致电。随时再打来。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "DR. WORM" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - “虫子博士”(Dr. Worm)，他们可能是巨人]
It's a simple, beautiful idea, that anyone, anywhere, anytime, can phone a number in Brooklyn, listen to one of They Might Be Giants' wonderful or wonderfully weird songs, and it doesn't cost anything more than any other normal call. Dial-a-Song's motto, "Free, when you call from work."
这是一个简单而美妙的想法，任何人，在任何地方，任何时间，都可以拨打布鲁克林的号码，聆听“他们可能是巨人”的精彩或古怪的歌曲，而且费用并不比任何其他普通电话高。“拨号歌曲”的座右铭是：“从公司打来是免费的。”
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
When John Flansberg and John Linnell of They Might Be Giants started their Dial-a-Song service 15 years ago, they didn't have a record contract. All they had was an answering machine and a dream. And that dream was to get people besides their friends to hear their music. Then they got a record deal. They were on the radio, on MTV, even.
当约翰·弗兰斯伯格(John Flansberg)和约翰·林内尔(John Linnell)在15年前开启他们的“拨号歌曲”服务时，他们并没有唱片合约。他们只有一台答录机和一个梦想。那个梦想是让朋友之外的人听到他们的音乐。后来他们签了唱片合约。他们上了电台，甚至上了MTV。
They considered dismantling the democratic empire of Dial-a-Song. But they were afraid their fans would accuse them of selling out, of turning their back on the people-- and by the people, I mean the people. And you can understand that the first year, the first five years, even. But it's been 15 years now. This funny little idea that they had back during the early Reagan administration, now, it's just who they are. Ladies and gentlemen, they rock the stage, they rock the records, they rock the phone lines.
他们考虑过拆除“拨号歌曲”这个民主帝国。但他们担心粉丝会指责他们为了赚钱而变节，背叛了人民——我所说的人民，是指大众。你可以理解前五年，甚至前五年。但这已经是15年了。这个他们在里根政府早期想出的有趣的小点子，现在，这只是他们本身的样子。女士们，先生们，他们震撼舞台，他们震撼唱片，他们震撼电话线。
Do you remember the first song, the first Dial-a-Song song?
你还记得第一首歌，第一首“拨号歌曲”吗？
I do. Because John said, I set it up. I was living in a different part of Brooklyn, so I phoned him up. And it was "Toddler Hiway." And he recorded it really quietly because we had this problem with the phone machine, where a loud sound with this particular model would actually tell the machine that that was the end of the message.
我记得。因为约翰说，我把它设置好了。我当时住在布鲁克林的另一个地方，所以我给他打了电话。那是“幼儿高速公路”(Toddler Hiway)。他录得很轻，因为我们的电话机有问题，这种型号如果声音太大，实际上会告诉机器那是留言的结尾。
It would think it was the beep.
它会以为那是哔哔声。
It would think it was the beep. So almost all our songs had to be kind of tamed. And that particular note was completely off-limits.
它会以为那是哔哔声。所以我们几乎所有的歌都必须经过某种驯服。那个特定的音符是完全禁止的。
Yeah, anytime there was a long note sung, we would have to break it up. We would actually sort of pop it out of the mix. So it would just be like, "I've been ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah," to kind of keep it from just returning.
是啊，任何时候有长音，我们都不得不把它切断。我们实际上会把它从混音中弹出。所以它听起来就像，“我一直啊-啊-啊-啊-啊-啊，”以此防止它直接挂断。
Sure, there are some adjustments you have to make if the telephone is the medium through which you express your art. But there are certain advantages to this system. You can monitor individual audience response in a way that's unavailable to more successful recording artists who restrict themselves to concerts and radio and TV-- you know, media where more than one person at a time can hear the song.
当然，如果电话是你表达艺术的媒介，你确实需要做一些调整。但这个系统有一些特定的优势。你可以以一种受限制于只在音乐会、广播和电视上——你知道，那种一次可以多人同时听歌的媒介——的更成功录音艺术家所无法企及的方式监控个人听众的反应。
Well, I think up until Dial-a-Song, we were the kind of guys who had a four-track recorder in their bedroom. And we would just overdub our voices or our instruments 5 million times, and go like, "Oh, listen to what the guitar sounds like if it's been overdubbed 5,000 times." And it would just kind of be, wahhhhhh. "Oh, that sounds really cool."
嗯，我想在“拨号歌曲”之前，我们是那种卧室里有四轨录音机的人。我们会给我们的声音或乐器叠加500万次，然后说，“哦，听听如果吉他叠加5000次听起来是什么样。”它就会像这样，哇……“哦，那听起来真的很酷。”
And then, doing Dial-a-Song actually made us realize, you're playing the song, people hang up in the middle, you can tell right away if they don't like-- you just sort of play your 5,000 guitar symphony over the thing. And two seconds into it, it's like, click. And you know that they hated it. So it really was-- it was definitely like rock school.
然后，做“拨号歌曲”实际上让我们意识到，你正在播放歌曲，人们在中间挂断了，你可以立刻看出他们是否不喜欢——你只是在播放你的5000吉他交响曲。两秒钟后，就发出咔哒声。你知道他们讨厌它。所以它确实是——它绝对就像摇滚学校。
It definitely moved us in a particular direction of really clarifying what we were doing, and also clarifying the arrangement, making it really simple sounding so that you could hear what was going on over the phone.
它绝对让我们朝着真正理清我们正在做的事情的方向发展，也理清了编曲，让它听起来非常简单，这样你就能通过电话听到正在发生什么。
Right now, somewhere in this nation, there's a music student spending thousands of dollars to learn a discipline that he might master more quickly if he'd just invest in a decent voicemail system.
现在，在这个国家的某个地方，有一个音乐专业的学生花着成千上万的钱去学习一门学科，如果他只是投资一个像样的语音信箱系统，他可能会学得更快。
Has it changed your ideas about where art comes from? Because I was reading that New Yorker article on Frank Sinatra. And there's this part where Ava Gardner runs out on him and breaks his heart. And he helps write "I'm a Fool to Want You." And then he stumbles into the recording studio and does it in one take and stumbles out in tears.
这有没有改变你对艺术来源的想法？因为我正在读那篇关于弗兰克·辛纳屈(Frank Sinatra)的《纽约客》文章。其中有一段是艾娃·加德纳(Ava Gardner)离开了他，伤透了他的心。然后他参与创作了《为你而痴》(I'm a Fool to Want You)。然后他跌跌撞撞地走进录音室，一次录制完成，又哭着跌跌撞撞地走出来。
But he actually always stumbled in and out of the studio.
但他实际上总是跌跌撞撞地进出录音室。
But also, if you talk to Billy May or talk to the people who put the arrangement together or the person who wrote the song, they might disagree about where the greatness of any given song comes from. They're involved in the process, too. A lot of people like to think of inspiration as being, you're lying on the side of a hill, and you're waiting for the clouds to cover and then the lightning to strike you. It's this really elaborate, long process of kind of waiting for it to happen. And sometimes, I think you can jump into the sky, grab the cloud, and grab the lightning yourself.
但同样，如果你和比利·梅(Billy May)交谈，或者和那些整理编曲的人，或者写歌的人交谈，他们可能对某一首歌的伟大之处来自哪里有不同意见。他们也参与了这个过程。很多人喜欢把灵感想象成，你躺在山坡上，等待云层覆盖，然后闪电击中你。这是一个非常精致、漫长的过程，等待它发生。有时，我认为你可以跳向天空，自己抓住云，抓住闪电。
Many, perhaps most, of the tunes on Dial-a-Song won't end up on a They Might Be Giants album. But all the songs on the band's albums have been previewed on Dial-a-Song, which means that their fans are in on their process. Here's how one of the band's best known singles, "Don't Let's Start," sounded in its initial Dial-a-Song form.
许多，也许是大多数，“拨号歌曲”上的曲子最终不会出现在“他们可能是巨人”的专辑中。但乐队专辑上的所有歌曲都曾在“拨号歌曲”上试听过，这意味着他们的粉丝参与了他们的过程。这是乐队最著名的单曲之一，“不要开始”(Don't Let's Start)，在最初的“拨号歌曲”形式下听起来的样子。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "DON'T LET'S START" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - “不要开始”，他们可能是巨人]
And this is the final, more compelling rock and roll "Don't Let's Start" that ended up on the album.
这是最终出现在专辑中、更引人注目的摇滚版“不要开始”。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "DON'T LET'S START" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - “不要开始”，他们可能是巨人]
The best lyrics in the song are ones they added over what had been just an instrumental bridge in the Dial-a-Song version.
这首歌里最好的歌词是他们在一个只是器乐过门的“拨号歌曲”版本上添加的。
[SINGING] No one in the world ever gets what they want, and that is beautiful. Everybody dies frustrated and sad, and that is beautiful. They want what they're--
[唱歌] 世上没人能如愿以偿，那很美。每个人都在沮丧和悲伤中死去，那很美。他们想要他们所——
John Flansberg says he's often surprised by how much They Might Be Giants fans keep track of a song's evolution.
约翰·弗兰斯伯格说他经常惊讶于“他们可能是巨人”的粉丝对歌曲的演变追踪得多么紧。
There's a song that's actually a bonus track on Factory Showroom. It's before track one, this song called "Token Back to Brooklyn." And I was talking to someone about this yesterday. And it was like this real-- It's the kind of thing that makes me feel like we are freak magnets because the guy was going, "In the song that was on Dial-a-Song, you said you wanted to kill your parents. And then you changed the lyric on the record--"
有一首歌实际上是《工厂陈列室》(Factory Showroom)的奖励曲目。在第一轨之前，这首歌叫“回布鲁克林的代币”(Token Back to Brooklyn)。我昨天刚和某人谈起这个。这就像是一个真正的——这是那种让我觉得自己像个怪胎磁铁的事情，因为那个家伙说，“在“拨号歌曲”里的那首歌，你说你想杀掉你的父母。然后你在唱片上改了歌词——”
To "tell our parents."
改为“告诉我们的父母”。
"To 'tell our parents.'" And I was just like, "Well--" And he was like, "And like, the reason you did that was, like, why?"
“改为‘告诉我们的父母’。”我当时就像，“嗯——”然后他说，“而且，你那样做的理由是，为什么？”
Because my mom was going to hear the record, maybe.
因为我妈可能会听到那张唱片，也许。
Yeah, and I explained to him that I really just didn't want to have any more songs about killing my parents.
是啊，我向他解释说，我真的只是不想再有关于杀掉我父母的歌了。
Any more songs?
再有歌？
Any more songs. Yeah, we've had songs about killing our parents before. And it really doesn't go over at holiday time. And so he was really disappointed. It was like finding out that Marilyn Manson--
再有歌。是的，我们以前写过关于杀掉父母的歌。而在假日期间这真的不怎么讨喜。所以他真的很失望。这就像发现玛丽莲·曼森(Marilyn Manson)——
Was a nice guy?
是个好人？
--takes the makeup off.
——卸了妆。
One of my favorite They Might Be Giants songs isn't a song at all, but a mysterious recording on the album Miscellaneous T, of two unidentified callers discussing the merits of Dial-a-Song, whose number they found in the band's ad in the Village Voice .
我最喜欢的“他们可能是巨人”的歌曲之一根本不是歌，而是专辑《Miscellaneous T》上的一段神秘录音，两个身份不明的来电者讨论“拨号歌曲”的优劣，他们在乐队于《村声》(Village Voice)上的广告里发现了这个号码。
What do you make out of that recording?
你觉得那段录音怎么样？
I don't know, [? Laurie, ?] I just don't--
我不知道，[劳里？]，我只是不——
Some kind of singing. They sound like all kinds of people, right?
某种歌声。他们听起来像各种各样的人，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And then it says, "Another child is born in India every time you call this number," right?
然后它说，“每次你拨打这个号码，印度就有另一个孩子出生”，对吧？
Yeah, right.
是啊，对。
Does that make any sense to you?
这对你有什么意义吗？
No, it doesn't make no sense--
不，那一点意义也没有——
And the guy that spoke, I don't know who he is.
还有那个说话的家伙，我不知道他是谁。
Yeah.
是啊。
But it doesn't sound like no answering machine, right?
但这听起来不像什么答录机，对吧？
No, it ain't an answering machine, because they're not saying anything. They're just--
不，那不是答录机，因为他们什么也没说。他们只是——
But what does he get-- how does he make money on this, whatever he's advertising in the paper? This is the part that don't make no sense. That's where the--
但那个家伙得到什么——他怎么通过这个赚钱，无论他在报纸上广告的是什么？这是最没意义的部分。这就是那个——
No, that was a woman who phoned up. And the reason why we had this long recording of her was that she was on a conference line with somebody else. This is another early--
不，那是个打电话进来的女人。我们有她这么长的录音是因为她和别人在电话会议线路上。这是另一个早期的——
Oh, and they were listening to it together?
哦，他们是在一起听吗？
--pop technology. Yeah, she and this guy she had phoned to tell him about Dial-a-Song were listening together. And then, when the machine finished its song, they had this conversation. And they had no way of disconnecting the third line. So we had about 45 minutes of them blabbering on.
——流行科技。是啊，她和那个她打电话去告诉他关于“拨号歌曲”的家伙一起听。然后，当机器放完歌，他们就聊了起来。他们没法断开第三条线。所以我们有了他们长达45分钟的胡言乱语。
They've got the craziest things in that paper. But this one here, There Must Be Giants, it's called. And it says, call machine. And they've got the phone number.
他们在那张报纸上有最疯狂的东西。但这个在这儿，叫“也许存在巨人”。它说，呼叫机器。他们有电话号码。
Yeah.
是啊。
But what kind of money does he make? It don't make no sense.
但他赚什么钱？这根本没意义。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Well, he don't make any money, right?
好吧，他根本赚不到钱，对吧？
No.
不。
Then he's a nut, right?
那他就是个疯子，对吧？
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
是啊，[听不清]。
Do you see any sense to that, There May Be Giants? That recording I have on [INAUDIBLE], did you hear it?
你觉得那有意义吗，“也许存在巨人”？我在[听不清]上的那段录音，你听了吗？
Well, I used to call it-- I would call it-- what's the motto? "Free, when you call from work."
嗯，我过去常叫它——我会叫它——座右铭是什么？“从公司打来是免费的。”
(SUBJECT) JOHN FLANSBERG: "Free, when you call from work." Yeah, a lot of people do call it from work.
(主题) 约翰·弗兰斯伯格：“从公司打来是免费的。”是啊，很多人确实是从公司打来的。
But I used to call it when I was really depressed, like so black and blue. And normally, in those situations, I'd try and feed it, and just get drunk and listen to Neil Young and cry myself to sleep. But on the healthier occasions--
但我过去常在我真的很沮丧的时候打，就像遍体鳞伤的时候。通常，在这种情况下，我会试着喂养它，只是喝醉了听尼尔·杨(Neil Young)哭着入睡。但在比较健康的时候——
Wow. You should hang out with my downstairs neighbors.
哇。你应该和我的楼下邻居聚聚。
On the healthier occasions, I'd go like, "I'm going to kick this thing and call Dial-a-Song." And I remember once being just so depressed and in tears. And I called it, and there was a song about how there was an ant crawling up my back. And it really-- it worked. It really cheered me up.
在比较健康的时候，我会想，“我要踢开这一切，拨打“拨号歌曲”。”我记得有一次真是太沮丧了，泪流满面。我拨通了它，里面有一首歌关于一只蚂蚁爬上我的背。那真的——它奏效了。它真的让我振作了起来。
It made you feel better. Yeah. See, some people wouldn't have that response to some of those songs. But I always felt like there was something at least happy about the music. For something so impersonal as a machine that you'd call up, that at least it was sort of merry in the music.
它让你感觉好多了。是啊。你看，有些人对那些歌可能不会有那种反应。但我总是觉得音乐里至少有些快乐的东西。对于像你打去的机器那样冷漠的东西，至少里面的音乐是某种程度上欢乐的。
It's better than that because it kind of includes both. Because it's very darkly merry. So it's kind of that sort of happiness that recognizes the dark side. So there's a whole other level. You had some new song at your show a couple of weeks ago that was very bright and happy, and it was about death, the death man or something like that. That's how I remember it.
它比那更好，因为它某种程度上包含了两者。因为它非常阴暗地欢乐。所以它是一种承认黑暗面的快乐。所以还有另一个层面。你在几周前的演出里有一首新歌，非常明亮快乐，是关于死亡，死亡男什么的。我记得是这样。
Yeah. Yeah, the death man.
是啊。是啊，死亡男。
I was picturing sickles.
我当时在想象镰刀。
That applies to most of our songs.
这适用于我们大多数的歌。
There's another reason besides this black humor that I call Dial-a-Song when I'm sad. I used to agree with John Linnell. I used to think it was just the deliciously dark They Might Be Giants music that cheered me up during those darkest hour Dial-a-Song calls. And that's part of it. But the thing that's just as reassuring about Dial-a-Song is the idea behind it, namely, that art, like life, doesn't always have to be a big production.
除了这种黑色幽默，我会在伤心时拨打“拨号歌曲”还有另一个原因。我过去同意约翰·林内尔的观点。我过去认为只是那令人愉快地黑暗的“他们可能是巨人”音乐在那些最黑暗的“拨号歌曲”通话中让我振作了起来。那是一部分原因。但“拨号歌曲”同样令人安心的事情是它背后的想法，即，艺术，就像生活一样，并不总是需要大制作。
Sarah Vowell is the author of the book Take the Cannoli . The often busy Dial-a-Song number-- get out your pens-- 718-387-6962.
莎拉·沃威尔是《带上卡诺里》(Take the Cannoli)一书的作者。那个经常忙线的“拨号歌曲”号码——拿出你们的笔——718-387-6962。
[MUSIC - "I'M SICK" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - “我生病了”，他们可能是巨人]
Act Three, Phone as History. Well, we think of our phone calls and phone messages as so transient, as throwaway moments. Here is another example of a personal human history captured by phone machine, in this case, by Barrett Golding in Bozeman, Montana. The messages were about his father.
第三幕，电话作为历史。嗯，我们认为我们的电话和留言是那么短暂，是转瞬即逝的时刻。这里是另一个通过电话录音机捕捉到的个人人类历史的例子，在这个案例中，是由蒙大拿州博兹曼的巴雷特·戈尔丁(Barrett Golding)捕捉到的。这些信息是关于他父亲的。
[BEEP] [BEEP] [BEEP] [BEEP]
[哔] [哔] [哔] [哔]
Hello, Ralph. This is Bea Levine, Janette and Ben Brooks, and Lester and Charlotte Bloom. We're all here having a little afternoon tea. And we wanted to talk to you, but I guess you're out. We want to know how Ralph is. Would you try to call us back one day and let us know what's going on? We all want to know how Ralph is doing. We hope he's doing well. Let us know. Bye.
你好，拉尔夫(Ralph)。我是碧·莱文(Bea Levine)、珍妮特(Janette)和本·布鲁克斯(Ben Brooks)，还有莱斯特(Lester)和夏洛特·布鲁姆(Charlotte Bloom)。我们大家在这儿喝下午茶。我们想和你谈谈，但我猜你出门了。我们想知道拉尔夫怎么样。你能试着回电告诉我们发生了什么吗？我们都想知道拉尔夫怎么样了。我们希望他一切都好。告诉我们。再见。
[BEEP]
[哔]
(SUBJECT) WOMAN 1 Mr. Golding, this is [? Dr.  Spark's ?] office, confirming your appointment for Tuesday, July 12, at 4:00. You don't need to call us unless there's a problem. Thank you.
(主题) 女人1 戈尔丁先生，这是[斯帕克医生(Dr. Spark)]的诊室，确认您7月12日星期二下午4点的预约。除非有问题，否则不需要打电话给我们。谢谢。
[BEEP]
[哔]
Hi, this is Rose Bernstein. Just calling to welcome you back, and hope you had a very good time. And we'd like to say hi to you. Bye-bye.
嗨，我是罗斯·伯恩斯坦(Rose Bernstein)。打电话只是想欢迎你回来，希望你过得愉快。我们想向你问好。拜拜。
[BEEP]
[哔]
It's Leah. I'm just heartsick over what happened. I'll get in touch with you later. [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
是利亚(Leah)。我为发生的事情感到心碎。我以后会再和你联系。[听不清]。
[BEEP]
[哔]
Hi, Mrs. Golding. It's Liz calling from Dr. Casey's office. I wanted just to give my condolences and tell you how sorry I am. I think we should touch base at some point. And I'll try calling you again later today. Bye.
嗨，戈尔丁夫人。我是利兹(Liz)，从凯西医生(Dr. Casey)的诊室打来的。我只是想表示慰问，并告诉你我有多么难过。我想我们在某个时候应该联系一下。我今天晚些时候会再试着给你打电话。再见。
[BEEP]
[哔]
Hello. It's 12:30. I just got a call in reference to Ralph. Please give me a call whenever you can. Thank you.
你好。现在是12点30分。我刚才接到了关于拉尔夫的电话。请在方便时给我回电。谢谢。
[BEEP] [BEEP]
[哔] [哔]
--going and is there anything I can do to help? We could--
——进行着，有什么我能帮忙的吗？我们可以——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[干扰声]
We're all very confused. So give me a call.
我们都很困惑。所以给我回个电话。
I wanted just to give you my condolences and tell you how sorry I am.
我只是想表示慰问，并告诉你我有多么难过。
It's Leah. I'm just heartsick over what happened. I'll get in touch with you later.
是利亚。我为发生的事情感到心碎。我以后会再和你联系。
[TAPE STOPPING]
[磁带停止]
Well, our program was produced by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Julie Snyder and Nancy Updike. Senior editor, Paul Tough.
好吧，我们的节目由阿里克斯·斯皮格尔(Alix Spiegel)和我本人制作，朱莉·斯奈德和南希·厄普代克(Nancy Updike)协助。资深编辑，保罗·塔夫(Paul Tough)。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Lyndon Johnson tapes are in stores everywhere. They are from Simon & Schuster. Joe Skyward did the music in Barrett Golding's story in Act Three. If you would care to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. The phone number, 312-832-3380. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
林登·约翰逊的磁带在各地商店均有销售。它们来自西蒙与舒斯特出版社(Simon & Schuster)。乔·斯凯沃德(Joe Skyward)为第三幕巴雷特·戈尔丁的故事制作了音乐。如果你想购买这一期或我们任何节目的盒式磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ。电话号码是312-832-3380。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes his job overseeing us this way.
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚(Torey Malatia)负责，他这样描述他监督我们的工作。
I would come home, and I would have to listen to, like, three, four hours of tape saying nothing. I mean dribble.
我回家后，不得不听三四个小时的磁带，什么内容都没有。我的意思是胡言乱语。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。